[Music]
jerome bruner's theory of development is
based on the assumption that we learn
best when we go from concrete to
abstract in a three-step
process first comes hands-on action
then learning with images and finally
students
transform what they've learned into
language
throughout the experience we constantly
revisit
previously learned topics while teachers
provide
carefully structured guidance along the
way and it seems
to work in the 1980s the singaporean
government decided to stop
importing foreign textbooks and instead
build the world's best maths curriculum
from scratch
since that time singaporeans study fewer
concepts with greater detail
following bruner's guideline before we
learn how well this worked out
let's go through each step of the theory
with an example
first we learn through inactive
representation
this happens in hands-on experiences
ideally with real-world applications
to divide four by two two students learn
to cut a cake into four slices
so each can eat one now and bring one
home
later step two
is iconic representation we now link our
memories of the experience to iconic
pictures
students are asked to draw a cake that
was cut into four pieces
last comes symbolic representation we
now use the images we internalized
earlier
and turn them into abstract language
such as mathematical
symbols using a little bit of
retrospection
we can easily solve the problem
this last phase is also called language
based
because we are really just learning the
right words and symbols to express our
thoughts
the actual maths knowledge was acquired
much earlier through hands-on
experiences
bruner therefore advocated for the use
of spiral curriculum
with continuous repetition of the same
fundamental ideas
the curriculum is comprised of three
characteristics
students revisit the same topic at
regular intervals
the complexity of the topic increases
with each revisit
the new learning has a relationship with
previous learning
teachers also use scaffolding a term
coined by bruner
teachers do this by structuring
activities based on students existing
knowledge
and in a way that helps them to reach
the desired learning outcome
the teacher first demonstrates the
process as the student watches
then the teacher lets the student have a
go steps back and offers support
and feedback when needed
[Music]
today by the way singapore's 4th and 8th
graders are the world's best in both
mathematics and science
and singapore's maths curriculum is
copied by educators from around the
world
jerome bruner was born blind in new york
city in 1915
at age two modern medicine restored his
vision
later he returned the favor by becoming
a pioneer in cognitive development
he believed that any subject can be
taught in an
intellectually honest form to any child
at
any stage of development
what do you think about bruner's theory
and his suggestion for better learning
is this how you learn in your studies if
not
what is one subject that you think could
be made more understandable by
following his ideas
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel
we try to explain complex subjects and
simple language and cartoons
to support students all around the world
in their learning
if you want to support us you can go to
www.patreon.com
sprouts and donate just one dollar from
many fans makes a big difference